we know it can certainly be dangerous
Realtors waiting to sell their home
Often by themselves in fact earlier this
year A man was arrested for allegedly
breaking into a model home and
assaulting a woman so how can you
protect yourself Candace Charles live
this morning at a local gym with a new
self-defense program created by a
realtor Candace good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
yes Serena Anderson as the realtor
created this training to make sure that
women are prepared for any type of
situation as John did mention there
there was an attack on a realtor back in
July she created this right after that
she's joined with me now she's on her
second class and I hear there's going to
be another one the response has been
quite amazing and unless it's personal
for you so why just I'd do it it's very
very passionate to my heart I want women
to to have the skills and the abilities
to protect themselves in any situation
where their boundaries are being
violated and to do this we have amazing
sponsors so I want to thank everyone and
all the businesses and if you any
businesses out there want to sponsor so
we can keep this going for free for our
community please reach out to us it
doesn't really cost that much but we
need some help to keep them going we've
had a huge response yeah so here you're
going to have another one in December
3rd this one's coming up Saturday
October 22nd one two three now I have
killing uh Jenkins here from 10 Tigers
martial arts he's going to show you a
little bit about what you can expect
from the class take it away um okay so
we're gonna do uh just in my 16 years of
martial arts you want to try to utilize
aggression and then use your weapons
your body weapons your elbows your palms
your fingers to the eyes and hit the
right targets okay so we're going to go
over this this is not one I would
usually teach but we're gonna do it
today okay so it sounds good we're going
to take somebody down all right so I'm
gonna come uh throw a punch she's gonna
block and Brace we're gonna come in hit
my thing put our fingers in my eyes and
then take me down okay it seems like
it's simple enough to try to do I think
I could do it maybe so I'm gonna put the
mic real quick so so I'm blocked oh nice
strike Boom come in
yeah yes
same thing it makes me feel powerful
really this Saturday October 22nd from 1
to 3 P.M it's completely free they have
food here drinks and everything and as
she mentioned they have their sponsors
helping them out it happens right here
at D1 training in Henderson from one to
three they have another one coming up on
December 3rd in Aliante I have all those
details for you on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from the D1
training in Henderson I'm Candace
Charles 8 News Now